former attacking Attorney General Sally
Yates testified before Congress today
regarding out the National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn's alleged ties to
Russia
Flynn resigned less than a month into
his term and revelations he'd lied about
meetings with Russian ambassador Sergei
kids lyac who had this is really boring
check um do we have that raw adult
dodgeball video instead oh man that
really liven up the intro oh right in
the lady balls you could hear it anyway
Flynn formerly headed President Obama's
Defense Intelligence Agency before being
fired in 2014 due to mismanagement
temperament issues and reportedly
destroying the Lincoln bathroom and
today this was Obama personally warned
Trump to stay away from flame maybe that
is the learning happening right there or
maybe it's a not my problem anymore bro
I don't know but
I'll tell you if you know anything about
trumpets that nothing dissuades him more
than telling him not to do something so
comedians what's another warning
President Obama gave to incoming
president Trump for Richardson if you
want to score weed from a Supreme Court
justice remember Ruth Bader Ginsburg's
got the good
all right point one mark Norman if you
want to win people over kill Osama bin
Laden oh wait I already did that three
those ephah they're not a civilian
anymore so you might want to avoid
Twitter yeah